[Music]
smack some photoshoot that you did in
promoting this movie this is an
incredible photo now I'm guessing that's
a fellow in a gorilla costume
it is indeed yeah who's in that costume
that is a very good question isn't it
that's a very intimate thing I saw that
photo and Myton being me I'm thinking
how do you get to be the gorilla boy I'm
sorry that's pervy but you do think well
you know actually we were kind of
wondering who it was a great concept and
I got to set that day and I was like ah
there's gonna be so much fun and then
you go wow but so who is actually gonna
be in the suit and so some poor guy or a
guy poor guy poor guy I don't want to
but if I have to it was one of the
lighting guys just pointed at someone
and say thank you you're the right size
get in it and you know I say poor guy
cuz he literally couldn't breathe so I
was you know in any was so he was okay
he was he wasn't like put his he was
literally like this and kind of shaking
I'm like just put them on like otherwise
he wouldn't the world is gonna see them
when they take the picture like cover my
nipples please and he's like okay and
it's a tough job market out there
they say there are no good jobs left in
America
[Applause]